hello Adam Smith hello Adam this is
Alice Munro I just wanted to thank you
very much this is quite a wonderful
thing for me it's a wonderful thing for
the short story it is indeed and may we
congratulate you in turn it's a
wonderful day thank you very very much
how did you hear the news let me see I
was wandering around this morning early
and how did I hear it first or the press
called me and what was your first
reaction
do you remember unbelief I I couldn't I
really couldn't believe it I was so
happy and I delight yet you've produced
an enormous body of work yes you know
because I work generally in the short
story form this is a special thing I
think to get this recognition hmm yes
indeed yes indeed
have you been basically the same sort of
writer from the beginning to the end
have you changed you think well you know
at first I can tell I have not changed
very much but someone else could answer
that question better I think and their
world will bring a great new readership
to your work well I would hold the sword
I hope this would happen not just for me
but for the short story in general
because it's often sort of brushed off
you know it's something that people do
before they write their first novel and
I like it to come to the floor without
any strings attached sort of it doesn't
have to be a novel and for those who
don't know your work would you recommend
a starting point oh goodness
I I don't know like I can't you always
think that your latest work is your best
at least I do so I would want them to
start with that the latest book so they
should start with dear life should they
well yes I hope they would go back and
read the others as well and of course
everybody is talking about the fact that
you announced earlier this year that you
were to stop writing and saying maybe
this would encourage her to start again
well you know I've been doing it for so
many years I bet I've been writing and
publishing I think since I was about 20
just know and then I would get something
published you know but that's that's a
long time to be working and I thought
maybe it's time to to take it easy
that's an exciting statement that's
going to have everybody buzzing how
splendid so I know that you must be
tired after speaking to 70 people so we
would like very much to talk to you
perhaps at another on another occasion
that's great actually
okay we'll wait till things quiet down a
bit and it's been a great pleasure to
speak to you thank you so very much
indeed thank you
you